Business is hard, but you can make it
easy if you have the right cheat codes.
So, it's something called a money model,
and they are responsible for the vast
majority of my material success, and I'm
launching it live August 16th. So, goal,
that sounds like a pretty big promise.
Let me tell you a little bit more about
the book overall. So, what is a money
model? So, a money model is a series of
offers deliberately structured to
generate the most upfront cash. That's
this guy. Get the most leads together,
and get the highest lifetime value,
which you generate by getting people to
buy again and again and again. And we
purposely also accelerate this cash flow
so that we can get them to buy in less
time. And by doing that, we can outspend
our competition and futureproof the
business. Because the one thing that I
can absolutely guarantee that will not
change in the history of mankind is that
the cost of advertising will only go one
way, which is up. How is it that some
businesses can be 100 plus years old and
other businesses struggle in their first
year despite the ones that are brand new
starting in this digital age? Whereas
these ancient businesses are still able
to out compete. The difference is a
money model. That's how you see
companies like JP Morgan. That's how you
see companies like Northwestern Mutual.
Some of these companies that are 100
plus years old, GE, that have existed
and been able to continue to exist, not
because they're hopping on some
influencer trend or because they have
the latest trending hashtag or they've
got meme music in the background, but
because they have a stronger money
model. So, money models are sequences
that when combined are so profitable,
they're responsible for the vast
majority of my material success. Like,
nothing else comes close. And to put
this in context, I have not talked about
the concepts in this book publicly. And
I started writing this in 2021 and I
have saved every single concept from
this book just for now and for the live
launch. So let me put this in context.
Most businesses have it completely
backwards, right? They spend money to
get customers and then they hope to make
it back over time. That's what makes
business so hard. That's playing on hard
mode. Money models is flipping that. You
make more money getting a customer than
it costs you to get them within the
first 30 days. That's the cheat code.
So, let me give you an example what this
looks like in action. When I started my
gym, you know, obviously things started
slowly, but then I started running ads
and things started improving. Now, that
worked for a minute until my ads became
too expensive. The algorithm changed
overnight, which happens over and over
again throughout, you know, time. And
all of a sudden, my cost of getting a
customer went from like $100 to like
$500. And I'm using these as
placeholders, but just say they went
from I could afford it to not afford it.
You can do the math here. If I charge a
$99 a month membership, which I did at
the time, and I'm spending $500 to get
them, I'm literally paying $400 out of
pocket for the privilege of having a
customer that I hope will someday make
me money later. Now, if that person
stays for, call it 10 months, then I pay
500 to make a,000. Kind of tough because
I still have other costs that I have to
make out of that 500, but like maybe
tenable, but not realistically tenable
because that means that I have to be
negative for 5 months before I make my
first dollar profit, which means I have
to front money that I might not have,
which is the situation that most
business owners find themselves in.
Option one is you either just burn
through your savings and pray. Option
two is you take on debt and then just
give away, you know, your future
essentially. Or number three is that you
take on cash from investors. You raise
money, then you sell, you know, sell
your equity, which you may or may not
want to do, or you just eventually go
broke and close the doors, right? This
is kind of what I was facing at this
moment. I was flying home for the
holidays. This is before I stopped
flying home for the holidays. And I was
at the airport and a guy that I knew in
college came up to me. He was like, "Oh,
you know, you know, how things going?" I
was like, "Oh, I started a business."
He's like, "Oh, well, I have two
locations." I was like, "So, what's the
business?" And he was like, "Oh, I have
a supplement store." I was like, "Okay,
how much you making out of the stores?"
And he said, "I'm making 80 grand and
130 grand a month between, you know, in
each one." And mind you, again, I didn't
ask him for bank statements, but that's
what he said. And I was like, "Holy,
like 80 grand a month." And I was like,
"If he can do that just selling
supplements," I was like, "And he
doesn't have members." I was like, "I've
got members at my gym. I'm sure I could
get at least a quarter of that if I
tried." I then, you know, bought a bunch
of supplements. I couldn't figure out
how to how to get them to to actually
buy, but eventually I was able to figure
out how to get them to buy. Once I did,
that took my person walking in the door
and then I was able to get them to buy a
few hundred in supplements in the first
48 hours. And then after that point, all
of a sudden, I could afford to run ads
again. That very small change of just
saying, "Oh, I'm just going to sell them
supplements after they come to my gym."
That change fundamentally changed the
economics of my business. It changed my
money model and as a result I was able
to now spend more than my competitors
who were at the at that time only
spending enough to just get enough
leads. They burn through their marketing
budget and then they had to wait till
the next month to reload up on
customers. And this is what allowed me
to continue to expand and expand until
the point that I open up new locations
over and over again because it made me
money to open locations which makes
absolutely no sense. But if you have a
money model, if you have a way of
getting customers to pay you more than
it costs to get them upfront, then
figuratively you unlock your ability to
get more customers. Now, you're going to
have other constraints in the business.
I had four walls. I had to get trainers.
I had other operational issues. But
getting customers and more succinctly
the cash required to get more customers
no longer was a constraint. Because if
every customer comes preloaded within
them, the cost of getting them, the cost
of delivering for them, and the cost of
getting the next customer, plus the cost
of delivering for the next customer,
when you have all four of those
preloaded in one in gross profit, you
can spend as much as you want. The only
thing worse than lighting fake money on
fire is lighting real money on fire,
which business owners do every single
day when they try to get customers and
the cost of getting customers cost them
more than the customers make them. And
fundamentally, if you do that for long
enough, you go out of business. And so,
it is the biggest threat to businesses
every single day. But there is a better
way, and the way you do that is with a
money model. Because money models show
you how to get more customers to spend
more money in less time over and over
again. And I'm going to be showing you
how to do this live at my money models
launch. So, click register and I'll see
you there.
The next question is like, well, so how
does this actually work mechanically to
get customers? In the book, after I
looked at all of the different
businesses that I've had over my career,
I realized that I could basically bucket
deliberate sequence of offers into four
buckets that kind of meet four different
objectives. And when you combine all
four, you maximize likelihood that you
generate the most cash flow from the
most customers in the shortest period of
time. So number one is you have
attraction offers. So these are offers
that maximize the likelihood of
conversion. So think about getting the
most leads to buy something. And these
ones tend to often have what I would
consider upfront cash components. So
things that pull cash flow forward. The
next is upsells, which is okay, now that
we've maximized the number of customers
that are walking the door, how can we
maximize the gross profit per customer?
So this is the getting them to spend
more money part. After that, we have the
downell component. We have customers who
come in and aren't willing to pay for
the most expensive thing, but they may
be willing to buy something. And so by
doing that, we turn nos into yeses. Now,
the key part is that downells are very
risky if you don't know how to do them
properly. If you do them the wrong way,
what ends up happening is you take all
your customers that were otherwise going
to pay for a more expensive thing and
they just buy a cheaper thing. That's
bad. So, we want to present the offer in
such a way that we get all the people
who are going to buy the first thing
that was the most expensive and then
also capture additional sales from
customers who otherwise would have said
no. I'll walk through that in in a
second in terms of more details. The
fourth element is continuity. Because if
you just got a bunch of cash up front
from people and you upsold and downsold,
well, then what do you have after that?
Well, you have a one-time transaction.
We don't get customers to make sales. We
make sales to get customers. And the
point there is we create a relationship
with a customer that increase the
likelihood they continue to purchase
from us again and again. There are offer
structure that each of these objective
points that increase the likelihood that
that objective occurs. We want to have
an offer that gets people in the door.
We want to have an offer that gets them
to spend more money. We would have an
offer that captures the other part of
people who who weren't originally going
to say yes. And then we want them to
have something that that gets them to
buy over and over again. If we have
those things, we have a model that can
outspend our competition. At least in
the most basic way, outspend the cost of
getting customers. If we think about
what is required for a business to
exist, you have to have cash. That's
literally it. Like you could have
nothing else, but as long as you can pay
your bills, as long as you can payroll,
as long as you can pay the incorporation
fee every year to maintain a business,
you are still in business. Your ego
might be bruised, you might have lower
revenue, you might not be hitting the
goals you want, but you are still in
business. If you have a money model that
increases the cash flow in the business
and pulls it forward, then by doing
that, you have a way that you can stay
alive. And what I have found from all
the people that I've known in in my
life, and I would say myself included,
is that business is an endurance game.
It's a marathon. It's about staying
alive and outlasting. And the way that
you outlast is you continue to have ways
to generate cash flow for the business.
So, I'm going to walk you through the
model that broke the gym industry. So
when I got into the gym game, what
people ran was something called an LBO,
which is not a leverage buyout, but they
called it that because it was a low
barrier offer. All right? And so this is
what those gyms did at the time. So they
would run a $21 21-day promotion, right?
So that was their front-end offer. That
was their attraction offer. Now, is that
a good attraction offer? Not by my
standards, but it was an attraction
offer for me. This would probably be a
downell, but for them, this is what they
were running on the front end. And
what's really interesting about all the
offer structures that I mentioned in the
Money Models book, which you'll soon
learn about, is that all of those offers
can be used anywhere, but I tend to
bucket them in this way because I think
they better satisfy this specific
objective. Back to the story. They were
running $21 21day promotions. And this
is back when people could in a local
market convert maybe 25 or even 30% of
leads. Lead quality has gone down on
those platforms. But let's just let's
just walk through it with uh with like
really bullcase scenario, the best case
scenario. So, they're closing one out of
four leads. So, let's say they get a 100
leads, which would cost them, let's say
that their their lead cost was 20 bucks.
All right? So, it's going to cost them
$2,000 to get 100 leads. Okay. Fine.
Now, they're going to convert 25% of
these leads and their price point is
going to be $21, which means that
they're going to make $525.
Well, that's in the first 21 days. Now,
of these 25, what percentage of these
people are going to convert to
continuity? this guy, the membership.
Well, the industry average for these
types of trials is 35%. So, let's just
call it a third and say eight of those
people are going to convert. And let's
say that their price point is $99. All
right. So, now they have another $800
here. Okay, fine. Now, the average stay
of a customer that's at $99 a month is
going to be usually, and this is kind of
sad, somewhere in the neighbor of like
fiveish months for the industry average.
It's much lower than you think it is.
And so that means that they've got
another $4,000 that's going to come in
off of these eight people. So all we
have to do is add this up. So they got
$525, they got 800 at the conversion and
then they got five more months. I'm
actually technically giving them six,
but let's just let's let's give it to
them. That means they were at 4,800 plus
that we're at 5325.
Now, if they spent $2,000 to make that,
it's okay. you know, they made some
money, but they still have rent, they
have admin, they have trainers, they
have other stuff that has to get
factored into this. I'm not even taking
into account gross profit here, which is
a huge factor. All right, but let's just
leave it at these numbers. That's okay.
You can kind of compete. You'll live,
but you're probably not going to make
much. And so, this is what I did in the
gym industry, and this is what changed
the game. I'll put this little number
here. So, remember we had 100 leads,
right? Well, we got we made 5325, which
means the maximum amount of money that
we could spend, right, from these would
be $53 per lead. Now, you couldn't
actually realistically spend that money
because you have every other cost in the
business you'd have to spend and you'd
be losing money. Let's just use that as
a hypothetic. And again, I'm just trying
to bolster this scenario. Now, what we
did was this. Someone would come in and
we ran a free sixe challenge or a six
week challenge, 42-day detox, 42-day
transformation, tons of different
rappers, but basically a six week thing.
All right? And so let's say we got our
same hundred leads. Now our 100 leads,
especially if we had a free offer on the
front end, would be usually about half
the cost. And so that means that let's
say we were spending, you know, they
spent 20 bucks a lead, we'd spend 10.
Now I'm going to again I'm going to make
this the worst case scenario for this
one. So let's say we spent 20. We spent
the same amount for these leads, even
though we wouldn't. Let's just say we
did. So we spent the same $2,000 to get
these leads. Great. All right. These are
our leads. Let's say we convert even
less of these leads. All right. Let's
say that we're going to convert 15% of
these leads. So, we're going to get 15
15 sales. Now, important point. I had
the perspective that when someone signs
up for something like a gym, their
highest point of motivation is the
moment they walk in the door. That is
when they're the most deprived of the
outcome. They literally they're they're
so in pain that they booked, you know,
they booked an appointment, they clicked
a lead, they opted in, they responded to
a a phone call, they got in their car,
they drove all the way there. They're
ready to change. That is the point that
I'm not trying to sell someone something
for 20 bucks. I'm trying to sell them
something for $500, right? The point of
greatest pain. Now, maybe it's $5,000,
but at the at this point in my career,
you know, $5,000 wasn't in my lexicon,
so 500 was was high ticket. All right?
I'd have 15 people that would come in
and I'd sell them for five or 600 bucks.
All right? So, let's just use 500 as
simple math. So, we would make $7,500.
Now, mind you, this is upfront. Upfront.
So, that means that if I'm spending this
money to get these customers in, I'm
already positive. I still have my
membership. I still have other things
that I can sell on top of that. But
remember here, we had to wait a month
plus to get to this 5325. Here, I'm
getting it day one. But after that, I
realized, wait a second, all these 15
people, I'll bet you I could sell 12 of
them on supplements. And so, the average
person there would spend about 200
bucks. So, I'd sp I'd make $2,400. Now,
gross profit on that, you actually have
physical costs there, but I ran close to
80% gross profit on the products that I
sold. that was roughly $2,000 in gross
profit that I'd make from selling these
12 people. All right, but you'd be like,
"Okay, well then that's already, you
know, 9500 compared to the 53." And this
is all within the first 48 hours because
I'd sell these people within the first
two days or so. And you might be
thinking, "Wait a second. I thought they
just bought a gym membership. Why would
you sell them supplements afterwards?"
Because people have different wallets.
They have different needs that can get
satisfied. And so just because you spent
all your money on your membership
doesn't mean you spent all of your
supplement money. And once you spend all
your supplement money, what else are you
going to do? Well, you're going to have
gym clothes, which is a different
wallet. And then once you buy your gym
clothes, what else are you going to buy?
You probably have to get food that's
going to be your new fitness food,
right? So all of these things have these
different buckets that customers are
willing to spend money on. And the and
the business that's able to capture the
highest percentage of that money in the
shortest period of time is the one
that's going to be able to out compete
and outspend. Now, let's continue. So
for me, remember this is a six week
thing that I sold them on. But does that
mean that I wait till the end of the six
weeks to sell them something else after
the supplements? Of course not. What
would I do? Well, I would say, "Hey, we
can take your $500 here and if you want,
we can credit it forward for the year."
How's that sound? If you just choose to
stay with us afterwards. Now, in the
first scenario, I've got no I've got no
leverage, right? I can't say like, "Hey,
you gave me $21. Let me put that $21
towards your $99." It's like, who cares,
right? But if I said, "Hey, I'm going to
take your $500 and put it towards a
year." That's real money. And so all of
a sudden, I could get somewhere in the
neighborhood of around 70% of people, so
double the percentage here, to take the
next offer. And so I take my 15
originally, and I've got about 10 who
stay on the back end. Now, at this
point, because I learned a little bit
more about pricing, instead of charging
99, I'd be charging $ 250 a month. And
then that would knock me down to about
$200 per month for my large group
training studio. Now, that means that
I've got $200 per month, which means
$2,000 per month in recurring. Now,
let's assume that I had the same stick
as them. Let's just assume that. Well,
now I've got $10,000 here, right? In
total, because times five, five months.
So, I got 10 grand here. But wait a
second. Do you think there's anything
else we could do? Great idea. I said I
had six weeks, right? And I got a
percentage of these people to say, "Hey,
I'm going to continue on and credit my
money." Fine. What What happens at week
six here? Well, I would still weigh them
out from their from their promotion that
I had, but what else would I do? I'd
say, "Hey, you're already committed for
the year. If you want, we can save you
another 10% if you just prepay today. I
saved you 500 on the first one. I'm
going to save you another 200 or 400 if
you take 10 or 20% off." Like, why not?
And I would get somewhere in the
neighborhood of 20 to 30%ish. Not a
promise, not a guarantee that if you do
this, this is what's going to happen.
I'm just giving you a rough estimate,
right? And so that means that I'm going
to get two or three people which kind of
factor I'll say in my experience it's
like 20ish% of customers so one out of
five will buy something that's
significantly more expensive. So
customers tend to be fractal 8020 right
and so here I would get somebody to then
spend call it $2,000. And so I'd make
let's just call this $5,000. We can take
the average here. $5,000 extra. Now
let's add up the difference here. My
competitors could spend up to $50 a
lead. That was very important right? 53
bucks elite is what they were able to
spend. But if we're adding ours up, I'm
going to get 7500 2,000 9500 10,000
19,500 plus five. So I've got 24,500
that I'm making from the same 100 leads,
remember? Which means that my ability to
spend is that I can spend $245
per lead at max. Here obviously I have
other costs, etc. But I just want to
make the math example simple. compared
to my competitor who could only spend
$53 per lead. 5x, not like 20% more or
50% more, but five times more. And all
of this money, and this is where it got
weird, all of this money minus this 5K
was in the first 30 days. Which means
that if I spent money on ads and I put
it on a credit card and I was able to
make $19,500
after I originally just put $2,000 in,
I'm getting $8 $9 back for every dollar
I put in. And I still have the lead. I
still have the customers. I can still
sell sell them lean by Halloween and
Slim for Santa. And I can still sell
them semi-private training. I can still
sell them other stuff, more supplements,
right, throughout the rest of the
relationship with the customer. And when
you do this, now let's let's think about
how why this is important. Why why I
bring up money models. The guys that I
that I was competing against
functionally sold the same product as
me. Maybe my trainers are better. Maybe
my location's a little bit better. But
fundamentally, they had trainers. They
had access to the same talent pool I did
locally. They had to pay their trainers
probably roughly what I was paying my
trainers. And so, how was it that I
could out compete them so clearly? I had
a better money model. And so right now
there's probably a version of your
business that can generate five, 10, 15
times more than somebody who's in
identical space as you. And I want to
push on this because a lot of business
owners have very limiting beliefs in
saying like, I don't think I could
charge that much. I can't I couldn't I
couldn't ask someone to buy supplements
2 days after they bought after they
bought a membership. Why not? They're
going to buy them either way. Might as
well buy them from you. But they didn't
finish the the six weeks or they didn't
finish the trial. Why would I ask them
to buy something else? Because they've
had a good experience up to this point.
and you make an offer so good they can't
refuse. Key point here is it's a
deliberate sequence of offers that's
structured to generate as much cash
upfront as humanly possible and maximize
the likelihood of conversion into
continuity or reoccurring. And if you
can accomplish that and for each of
these elements there's multip so like
let's walk through some of the examples
here. their money model, call it a free
trial almost, but a low ticket front-end
offer that was basically a a paid trial
functionally. And then they just had a
continuity offer on the back end, which
is $99 a month, but there was no
mechanic. There was no there was no
there was no lubricant there. It's just,
hey, you bought this thing. You're the
end of your trial. Do you want to buy
the next thing? What's crazy is that
this is how a lot of businesses run. But
the thing is is that wouldn't it be more
compelling if we said, "Hey, you want to
take the $21 and put it towards
something like that would be more
compelling than just saying buy the next
thing." So now let me show you the
pieces that are involved in this one. So
we had a win your money back as offer
one, which is an attraction offer, which
then rolled into a classic upsell, which
is the supplement offer. You can't buy X
without Y. which then rolled into a
rollover upsell, which is how I took the
cash that they had here and put it
towards membership. It's the third,
which is uh which is an upsell offer
combined with a continuity offer. And
then I did a buy X to get Y, which was
the paid and full discount. Buy 10
months, get two months free as the offer
at the end. Now, are all of these
continuity offers? Well, two of these
are kind of, but the mechanics behind
what make the offer compelling is the
components of the money model. That
lubrication, that reason why, that
compelling thing that gets someone to
say yes more likely than no, that is
what can transform a business. And these
are the tricks of the trade that people
rarely share publicly. And it's because
it's the engine. It's the machine. I've
spent the last 13, 14 years documenting
all the little things, the little
nuances, the how I say this and then
that gets them to say this. And if I
present the price like this first and
then I say this, then I get way more
people to take it. Those mechanics are
what create a money model. Want to hear
something insane? My next book, $100
million Money Models, is finally coming
out. Want to hear something else insane?
Every single person who shows up live to
the book launch event gets a secret
project that I've been working on for
over two years. And I can't tell you
what it is, but it's less than a bitcoin
and it's more than an NFT. And every
single person who shows up gets one. And
what's that? Oh, yeah. If you choose to
pre-order a copy of the book, there's
four amazing bonuses that you get
absolutely free if you just choose to
pre-order it because it helps my
warehouse team out. It would mean a lot
to me. You don't have to do it because
what's that? Oh, yeah. You can show up
for free. And so, no obligation either
way. I would love to see you there, but
the free prizes are there only if you
show up live. So, click register and
it's going to be awesome.
And so where does money models fit
within kind of the universe of the $100
million series, right? The first book,
$100 million offers teaches how to
create an offer so good people feel
stupid saying no. Said differently, if
you were selling a straight membership,
you're going to lose compared to
somebody who's selling a transformation.
If you're selling, hey, just come get
workouts versus, hey, we're going to do
a grocery store tour with you once a
week to make sure that you know what to
buy. And on top of that, you're going to
have an accountability coach who's going
to check in with you every morning to
make sure that you weigh in and that
you're, you know, attending your workout
later. And on top of that, you're going
to have a group of people who are just
like you who are going alongside. And we
also have prizes for people who are
winning. On top of that, we've got meals
that we can you can order through us if
you want that are already, you know,
pre-approved. We also have these
supplements that can help you feel
better and make this feel less bad as
you're doing it. You go through all the
different potential issues that someone
might have and we say, "How do we flip
all of the objections that someone has
and make it into an offer?" If you don't
have an offer, there's nothing you can
sell, right? You will sell a commodity.
Memberships between two boot camps is
the same thing. But if we have a
transformation, now all of a sudden we
have more stuff that's going to be more
compelling and more differentiated,
which will then allow us to command a
higher price. I had to start there
because if you don't have an offer to
sell, there's nothing I can do. The next
is leads, right? So once you have the
offer, you're like, "Okay, I got the I
got the thing I'm going to sell. I've
got my transformation, whatever,
whatever your transformation is, right?
How am I going to let people know about
it? Leads shows you how to advertise,
how to get leads, how to get customers,
right? Which is either you're going to
have some sort of content that you're
making, you're posting stuff. You're
going to have some sort of outreach that
you do, which is you DM, you cold call,
you you you're you're you're emailing.
You have some sort of advertisements
that are paid that you run. And you can
do those to get customers to send you
referrals. You can do those to get
affiliates who also send you customers
as well, right? And so those are the
different sources that you're going to
get. I can go into more details, but
that's that is the gist of $100 million
leads. And so now you're like, I got a
thing and I got a way to let people know
about it. Well, then the money model
comes in is to connect all the dots is
it puts it runs the water through the
funnel through the pipeline. And the
idea is we put the advertising in on
this side and money comes out the other
side. And so it teaches you how to get
more customers to pay more money faster
over and over again with all four types
of offer structures that when you design
a good money model, you're going to use
multiple. I told you I just I gave you
four that I was using in this money
model. And by combining those Lego
blocks and you're going to for your own
business mix and match, there's five
attraction offers that I have in the
book. It's like, okay, I'm going to use
attraction offer one here. I'm going to
use upsell offer two here. I'm going to
use attraction offer four here. and I'm
going to use downell offer two and three
here. And then I'm going to use
continuity offer four on the back. When
you put that together, that is how you
assemble the business. That is how you
outspend everyone. That is how when
Facebook ads become expensive, you don't
care. And that's why that guy goes out
of business and you stay in business and
you keep growing. Believe it or not, the
offers, leads, and money models books
were actually all one book that I first
started writing in 2021 and it was
called Lead Generation and Monetization
Structures. very very sexy title. And so
I wrote it as a textbook because I I
thought I was an academic. I thought I
was, you know, very fancy. When I wrote
it though, the thing is I had a couple
meaty sections in that I was like, "Man,
this is like really really dense. I feel
like I have to unpack this." Believe it
or not, the lead's book actually was
just one very long chapter in that book.
And I was like, "Okay, I need to I need
to talk more about this. Like no one's
going to be able to just take this
chapter and then immediately use it." So
I had to write the leads book. But then
I was writing the leads book. I was
like, "Well, shoot. None of these ads
are going to work. none of this posting
content is going to work unless they
have an offer. So then I had to peel out
the offer section, which was really the
very beginning of the book, just saying,
"Hey, you got to have something
compelling to sell that people don't
price compare you on. Here's the how you
make an offer. Here's how you put it
together. Here's the value equation.
These all together are actually one
system of acquisition. Now, to be clear,
you could take just the leads book and
advertise your stuff and you'll make
more. more people find out about
whatever it is you have. Even if you
have just the most basic membership in
the world, more people find out about
it, you'll have more customers, right?
If you only had a better offer, if you
go from a membership to a sixe
challenge, you're going to have a more
compelling offer. More people will buy.
Sometimes systems have multiple
dependent components. So like for a car,
if I don't have wheels, the car won't
go. But if I have wheels and I don't
have an engine, the car still won't go.
On the other hand, if I have a pipeline
of water that's going through a pipe, if
I make one part thicker or thinner, I
can still increase the throughput of the
pipe overall. And so, in this type of
setup, all of these are additive.
They're multiplicative. All of these
things just make businesses better.
Think of them as business enhancers, if
you will. Sometimes you're only one
crazy offer away. You're only one big
advertising campaign away, or you need
the cash flow to support both of those
things through having a superior money
model. And so to be clear, you don't
need to read offers or leads in order to
use money models. But if you do, it'll
be even better. But you don't need to.
Just like if you don't read money
models, you can just advertise more and
your business will grow. The followup
question might be like, what if I have a
small business or a big business? Like,
how will it work for me? Well, it
doesn't matter what industry or size
you're in. A money model is core to
every business. The question is just how
good yours is and how many different
components you've implemented so that
you can maximize each of those
objectives. This is the most how to win
at business manual that I've ever made.
And I truly believe that it will change
people's businesses and lives more than
anything I've ever released. And to be
clear, gym launch as a business was
functionally structured on just having
superior money model in two ways. I
showed a superior money model for gyms
to run, which allowed them to advertise
in more ways, in more places, more
profitably, get better talent so they
could out compete people in their area.
But I also had a superior money model at
the gym launch level. my business that
showed how this money model worked
because other people were in that space
trying to help gym owners out whether
they were marketing agencies or they
were they sold courses or whatever they
sold to the same avatar, right?
Equipment companies, all of these
companies sold to the exact same avatar.
If we think about it like this, you have
a person that your business sells to.
And this person is going to have, let's
say it's a gym owner, he's going to have
equipment dealers who are trying to get
his his eyeballs. You're going to have
supplement sellers who are going to try
and get them to wholesale. You're going
to have uh marketing agencies who are
going to say, "Hey, you know, buy, you
know, buy our services." You're going to
have construction companies which are
going to say, "Hey, do remodels for your
gym." You're going to have apparel
companies that are trying to say, "Hey,
use our apparel line to, you know, to to
do it at your gym." And so, all of these
people have to buy ads on the same
person. All of them are buying
advertising space for these eyeballs.
In an auction of attention, the person
who can outspend, let's say this one's
the biggest, can have an ethical and
legal monopoly of the attention of their
prospect or their ideal avatar simply
because of the economics of their
business. They make more money on this
person's eyeballs than all of these
people. And so for all of the blank
spaces on this person's news feed, this
guy can put his barbell ads over and
over again. And so what happens is that
you can actually outspend and increase
the CPMs in your marketplace such that
no one else can compete. Hopefully you
see the difference between a generic gym
that sells a membership
and this gym model and the biggest one
is how the money works, how the money
flows, how quickly, and to whom. And
when you have that, you can be this
business that outspends the remainder of
other businesses that compete for the
same attention. And by doing that, you
can win. This is an overview of the
conceptual hierarchy of the ideas that
are contained within the Money Models
book. These are the nitty-gritty tactics
that only the pros know and that most
people keep close to their chest. I
always know that a book is good when I
feel very insecure before I release it
because I'm like, "Oh my god, these are
all my secrets. What am I going to do?"
But I've learned enough times that uh
the more money I make other people, the
more money I end up making. If you're
like, "Man, this sounds really
interesting or this sounds really cool."
Then I'm having the launch event of the
season. I'm spending millions of dollars
on the launch event just because I want
to blow you guys away. You can register
for the live launch event. It's August
16th. You can register for it now. It's
register.acq.com.
What's beautiful about this is that the
whole event's free. I've got five
mystery speakers that are coming out.
They're headliners and they've never
shared the same stage before and many of
them don't speak publicly much at all.
It's gonna be awesome. But beyond that,
I'm going to be showing you the concepts
in this book in real time and I'm gonna
be pulling them out and you like you
probably even heard some of these things
that I said today and you're like, "Oh,
I could use something like that." Well,
imagine an entire book of those and
you'll be able to pre-order a book
before the uh before the live launch
event because it actually helped my
warehouse team out a lot. And so to
incentivize you, I've got four amazing
bonuses that you can find out about when
you go to the register.acq.com page. And
I have a surprise gift
that I have been uh saving for a while
now that I've been working on for more
than one year, multiple years in
anticipation of this event that I will
be releasing live at the launch. And
every single person who shows up live
will get one. And uh I can't say what it
is yet, but I can tell you that it's
it's better than an NFT and it's less
than a Bitcoin. And every single person
will get one, but you got to be there
live. All right. So it's
register.acq.com. Over the next four
weeks, I'm gonna be revealing one model
per week.